- Hello AP Calculus students.
This is Sal Khan of the Khan Academy.
And as well all know,
the AP Calculus exams,
both the AB and BC exams
are coming up this Thursday, May 5th.
And I'm sure you are buzzing
with as much excitement as I am.
And in case you didn't already realize it,
Khan Academy has a lot of
resources for you in calculus.
You could either jump
in and learn the things
that you wanna learn, or we
have what we call our missions,
where it'll guide you
through all the calculus
that you need to learn for
either the AB or the BC exams.
But on top of that,
in preparation for this
super exciting exam,
on Monday, May 2nd, we are
going to have live office hours.
And so from 4 to 5 PM
Pacific Standard Time,
it will be myself and Grant,
who is our calculus fellow,
and we will be answering your
questions about calculus.
It could be reviewing things.
It will be going through example problems.
Or we might point you
to the right resources
on Khan Academy itself.
And so, show up.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
You do not want to miss out on this.
And anything that you want us to cover,
go to the Facebook post
about this live stream
that we're gonna have on
Facebook on Monday, May 2nd
and put your questions, tell
us what you want us to cover,
what you're confused about,
or any example problems
that you wanna see.